بالفعل هي من اكثر المناطق
دمارا وهي من اكثر المناطق التي يعني تدمي
القلب يعني انا الصوره دائما ابلغ من
الحديث والكلام لذلك ساجول معك في
الكاميرا ولكن بين الامل وبين يعني الياس
والبكاء والانتظار والامل خطوات بصيره
بسيطه جدا هذه عائله تركيه طبعا كانت في
حاله انهيار بعد ان خرج احد اعضاء احد
افراد العائله من تحت الالقاب وهو اشلاء
وكانوا في حاله بكاء ولا زالوا ينتظروا
حتى هذه اللحظه المزيد من افراد العائله
لا زالوا تحت انقاض هذا المبنى على يسار
الصوره طبعا هنالك ايضا عائلات اخرى من
وراء تنتظر اشخاص لا يزال تحت الانقاض
عالقين في هذه البنايه في هذا المجمع
السكني في وسط انطاكيا طبعا هذا انا كنت
تحدثت الى هذا الشاب اسمه عبد الله
وساتحدث اليه على على الهواء لاستمع القصه
لاني اودت ان اسمعها منه على الهواء
التالي شخصيا عبد الله كنا اتفقنا اننا
نحكي معك اولا انت من اين جئت من وين جبت
من سوريا مين الك هون مين بتستنى
كم عددهم اربع اشخاص
يعني انت مش ما حدا من اسرتك هون اصدقائك
اصحابك
كم عمرك انت 17 وهم من عمرك لا واحد من
عمره والباقي يعني اهله ثلاثه اهله وهو من
عمره يعني صار بعرفه تسع سنين الحمد لله
هو حافظ لكتابه الكريم بس بتمنى انه هيك
يشوفوا يعني ماني خايف انه اذا توفى بس
بتمنى انه يشوفوا
ابدا من بالي بحيس اتمنى
يعني كان يتم يونسني
عندك احساس لانه اليوم اخرجوا شخص على قيد
الحياه
باذن الله راح يطلع حي باذن الله لا
تقنطوا من رحمه الله يعني انت جئت هنا عبد
الله تستنى صديقك يطلع طبعا وعائلته ان
شاء الله هو بيطلع باذن الله اذا الله قدر
ان شاء الله بس يطلعوا بروحي بفديه بس
ايش بدنا نسوي الله يحميك ان شاء الله
يطلع حي وان شاء الله تشوفوا وتستمر
صداقتكم يعني طول السنه ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يطلع على قيد
الحياه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يطلع على
قيد الحياه احمد انا هذا مشهد يعني مؤثر
هذا الشاب ينتظر صديقه يعني لا يريد سوى
ان يراه ولكن انا ساجول ايضا معك
بالكاميرا لتشاهد المنظر والمشاهد هنا
والدمار الهائل الذي يحدث طبعا نحن في وسط
مجمع سكني مدمر بالكامل على جانب نهر
العاصي هذه العائلات هنا هؤلاء الاشخاص
ينتظرون ايضا اشخاص تحت الانقاض لا زالوا
تحت الانقاض لهم عائلات لا تزال تحت
الانقاض
وفرق البحث تعمل على مدار الساعه
اليوم نكون اود ان اسالك عمار يعني ماذا
عن فرق الانقاذ كيف تقيم الوضع